[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres türkisches
gericht ich mache heute qisda wasser das
im kebab gericht kerber ich habe schon
oft erzählt ist ja nicht nur dünner
kepper also was ihr vielleicht so vom
imbiss kennt sondern kemper bedeutet
einfach fleischgericht und da gibt es
wirklich ganz verschiedene arten wie man
kebab gerichte zubereitet ob sie
geschmort sind oder gegrillt sind es
wirklich komplett unterschiedlich ich
mache heute ein rezept aus gaziantep
kilic kasse also ein ofen cap ab was
aber in so einer pfanne zubereitet wird
gas ein tipp liegt im südosten
anatoliens und ist einfach eine provinz
in der es wirklich super leckere
gerichte gibt ich selbst war leider noch
nie dort aber wir nehmen es uns vor wir
wollen da unbedingt mal hin reisen und
da kommen auch pistazien herr gaziantep
also richtig lecker und heute machen wir
ein gericht es besteht aus kartoffeln
und ebner fleischmasse ich sage mal die
zutaten die sind wirklich super einfach
die zubereitung ist einfach ihr könnt
sie wieder perfekt vorbereiten und es
ist einfach ein rezept war es in den
backofen kommt und dann kann man einfach
was anderes erledigen also auch super
einfach ich verwende dafür 800 gramm
geschälte kartoffeln das sind jetzt
vorwiegend festkochende kartoffeln
ich habe ich einen rosmarinzweig aus dem
garten 50 gramm wasser etwas salz und
muskat die zweite schicht ist dann die
fleisch schicht dafür nämlich 800 gramm
hackfleisch ist jetzt vom rind eine rote
und grüne spitz paprika 2 knoblauchzehen
eine zwiebel etwas olivenöl und hier
habe ich noch die gewürze ich nämlich
etwas salz und pfeffer berg bohnenkraut
süßes paprikapulver etwas chili und eine
prise zimt hier schon mal den ofen
vorgeheizt auf 190 grad ober unterhitze
und kann jetzt ihr mich um die
kartoffeln kümmern
die hatte ich einfach nur in wasser
gelegt damit sie nicht braun werden weil
ich seh schon gestellt habe und das
gestellte gewichtheben auch abgewogen
habe und jetzt werden sie in feine
scheiben geschnitten also entweder mit
dem messer oder mit einer küchen hobel
ich nehme jetzt einfach denn alles
schneider weil es schneller geht und ich
mache etwa 3 mm dick
das ging jetzt hier super schnell habe
ich hier die kartoffeln
da gebe ich jetzt noch wasser dazu
einfach zum vorgang rosmarin den habe
ich vom garten den lasse ich jetzt so im
ganzen
sie beschreibt ihn vor so ein bisschen
ich liebe einfach groß marin mit
kartoffeln dass die beste kombi etwas
salz und muskat hole ich mir kurz eine
reibe muskat passt auch immer perfekt zu
kartoffeln und entweder könnt ihr es
jetzt in so einem blech backen oder in
eine auflaufform am besten nimmt ihr
aber etwas was ihr abdecken können
deswegen mache ich jetzt hier gleich in
der gusseisen pfannen und einfach den
deckel drauf geben kann
ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr das nicht
habt einfach so ein blech nehmen und
dann zum beispiel noch ein pizza blech
darüber stülpen dann ist es auch
verschlossen
ich nehme jetzt aber trotzdem gusseisen
denn darin werde ich später servieren
darin bleibt das essen nämlich auch
schön lange war weil einfach gusseisen
die wärme speichert so das wasser auch
mit nach drüben schütten
jetzt kann ich hier die kartoffeln und
schon mal vorgang damit die einfach ein
bisschen weich werden
die kommen jetzt in den backofen bei 190
grad ober unterhitze und da lass ich so
etwa 15 bis 20 minuten vorgaben und kann
in der zwischenzeit die hackfleisch maße
machen
[Musik]
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen habe ich
bereits geschält und jetzt müsst ihr im
prinzip einfach nur das gemüse kurz
richtig fein hacken
ihr könnt auch mit einem mixer kurz vor
mixen aber ich mache jetzt einfach ganz
großen messer alles schön feinen könnte
auch reiben
jetzt kommt ich hasse das
eben weil ich noch nicht glücklicher
zwiebel schneiden zwiebeln und jetzt
soll die krokodilstränen
die paprika ist auch richtig schön fein
hacken
ich nehme jetzt aber hier noch die kerne
innen heraus die rote spitz paprika ist
nicht scharf
die grüne bei der kann sein dass ihr
schaf ist also wenn ich es gerne scharf
möglich nimmt eine richtig schöne
scharfe paprika ansonsten eher milde
aber ich glaube die dürften nicht so
scharf sein
alles schön find es gibt es nicht schön
aus und jetzt wird im prinzip alles nur
vermischt also hier das gemüse jetzt
rein
wir können das ganze theoretisch auch
vegetarisch zu bereiten und vegetarisch
wird dann sogar vegan bedeuten wenn ihr
einfach statt das hackfleisch etwas mehr
gemüse nimmt und da könnt ihr das gemüse
wirklich super auch mischen hier noch
die gewürze die muss ich jetzt nur noch
grob zerkleinern denn meinberg
bohnenkraut noch nicht zerkleinert das
habe ich nämlich aus dem garten da noch
das ölreiche muss es nicht unbedingt
sein das könnte dazu geben
es kommt einfach darauf an wie fertig
oder hackfleisch ist und jetzt einfach
kurz alles mischen
ich hatte das hackfleisch übrigens
aufgetaut ich habe nämlich immer ein
bisschen was im vorrat im gefrierfach
ist alles schön verkneten
oh wie ist das hier auch gut passt dass
wir sind kreuzkümmel ich glaube ich gebe
noch kreuzkümmel dazu ja so ein
teelöffel
und dann warte ich jetzt einfach ganz
kurz auf die kartoffeln die sind auch
gleich so weit
und dann ist schon fast alles erledigt
kann ich kurz aufräumen und händewaschen
lecker rosmarinkartoffeln es für mich
einfach so der beste duft ich nehme
jetzt aber den rosmarin raus der hat
nämlich seine arbeit getan
ahu aber es geht ach so war die
kartoffeln sind schon super
und jetzt kommt hier die fleischmasse
drauf einfach schön flach drücken
und jetzt kommt noch die deko dran
deco darf nämlich nicht fehlen ich lege
zugleich noch tomaten spalten drauf und
zu spitz paprika tirol ich kurz so
typisch türkisch dass man mit paprika
und mit tomaten dekoriert weil die dann
einfach auch noch auf der oberfläche
schön gegrillt werden und das passt
einfach immer super dazu hier noch spitz
paprika und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr
hier sogar das ganze noch bissl
eindrücken wie so eine art wie schon
eine art kuchen schon mal markieren
indem ich jetzt mal an den griffen und
dann mache ich sex teil oder 12 nicht
ganz mittig aber etwas schief das machen
wir nochmal ich jedoch mein kuchen ein
teilnehmen können
was da hier ein okay hier ist die mitte
das heißt hier einmal durch oder den
rest karriere einfach mit der deckung
ja ich glaub sechs portionen das passt
doch schubert dann ist es wie so eine
hauptspeise aber auch nicht zu viele je
nachdem ob jetzt noch eine vorspeise
habt oder auch noch nachtisch finde ich
die portionen echt super die mittlere
portion ist etwas größer die kriegt dann
der papa im haus und die kleineren
einfach die kinder ganz einfach und
lasst uns auch den paprika steen so ein
bisschen überhängen denn jetzt wird das
ganze nicht mehr geschlossen gegart ich
möchte nämlich dass es hackfleisch auch
schön wie gegrillt wird auf der
oberfläche also jetzt einfach ohne
deckel weiter garen und so könntet ihr
sitzt theoretisch auch gut vorbereiten
abgedeckt in den kühlschrank stellen und
dann einfach kurz vor dem essen schön
nochmal erhitzen also ich brauche jetzt
hier so etwas nochmal 20 25 minuten
die genaue angabe schreibe ich euch
später einfach in die app so dass
einfach die oberfläche schon gar ist
also das fleisch und kartoffeln sind
sowieso schon durch alles auch noch so
ein bisschen an geröstet wird von oben
und dann ist fertig ich nehme die hand
das ist das schöne gericht im backofen
mein job ist jetzt fertig und murat darf
probieren schatz nimm dir aber gabel und
messer mit ja ich geb dir jetzt nur eine
halbe portion denn das team möchte mit
essen
ich habe leider keine gabel messer
gefunden habe
das nehme ich eine kleine gabe es ist
richtig und ich habe schon ewig auf
klatsch abgewartet und wie nennt sich
das ziel ist aber viel ist aber okay das
ist ein bisschen ein kroatisches kapitza
im schnitt plesca bitzer kroatisch
probiert man hielt eine google und dann
den kalten joghurt dazu mit chili drauf
macht halt immer jetzt nicht mehr so
scharf wie ich früher wegen den kids so
hunger gehabt nämlich ganz sachsen royal
trust zu sagen es super wirklich so
richtig habe ich weiß ja was sie sagen
sollen wenn das kleine nach stets auf
die gabel auch ein schönes gericht was
man perfekt fabriken machen ist
unbedingt und ich finde sie doch echt
schön aus doch drin
ich hab so hunger gehabt nicht
wahrgenommen das ist auch wunderbar
ignoriert mich immer ich rede mit ihm
und antwort
disqualifiziert in seiner rolle als
verkoster warum man wenn du nur herkunft
um den bauch vollzuschlagen jobs hat den
leuten sagen wie es schmeckt mein
reschen gedicht er sich eine kunst es
ist wahnsinn
die kartoffeln die schmecken herrlich
nach jahr ähnelte schönherr man merkt
dass du dir die mühe gemacht das und sie
vorgegart genau und es hat man im
nachhinein sollten so einen schönen
runden abgang will muss dann ist dann
auch wahnsinn und die hackfleisch masse
darauf und noch nie hat qualität ist ein
perfektes gericht
die tränen gekommen sind keine bürger
gebrauch einfach keine beinahe dazu denn
es ist ein vollwertiges und und und
runde setting in das gericht oder
verstehen da ich keine beilagen braucht
euch nicht mehr
danke ich muss irgendwann mal aus der
nase ziehen weil da braucht jetzt kein
reis dazu keine extra gekochten
kartoffeln oder kein gemüse ist es
einfach so wie es ist perfekt machte
einfach vielleicht eine kleine vorspeise
dazu oder eine schöne nachtisch auch
beim blog findet ihr übrigens immer so
kleine menüvorschläge also da könnt ihr
gerne mal vorbeischauen oder in der app
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
mach's gut du langsam essen langsam
essen und genießen russischen dass das
team noch ich habe noch ein bisschen
schupfnudeln mit sauerkraut und das
ganze wieder international paradies nach
nein erst wenn alle da sind kann man
alle kurz rufen alle kommen bitte
[Musik]